what the [ __ ] Paden Adam and do this
Oh Satan I all do
purity pad just you and me huh you want
Stefano you want to find out huh no you
can't have the fam you mean oh oh come
on give me a break scene and oh well
that's Jesus on a pony cuz I'm pretty
goddamn trunk good idea PD you're pretty
smart I uh
they're like turned against here you're
screwed up I need to get in that room
huh I don't need to get it you're dry
you lied to me
I lied me you lying lying son of a [ __ ]
okay the [ __ ] are you doing and skully's
I'm just gonna leave you guys there you
can hang out you can do whatever you
want you're gonna go to the beach
together you can good penises with
really big balls by the way it's balls
are freaking huge
okay you don't key
oh my slope with you though still
watching that thinking down okay I get
it like it it's pretty interesting
Cheryl tell me what to do I don't know
Pete I really don't know I wish I could
tell you but I'm a sheriff sir when the
monster comes I'm like cher mode
activated wait and he doesn't attack me
super awesome you should try share mode
really try Shamu oh oh [ __ ] you seen
here somewhere I wish I knew the share
mode
seriously though we're supposed to go
back okay what is this my blood already
was and stuff okay okay okay I think
[ __ ] is he raping stuff now ah here we
go
huh he sees me
the okay we're good
okay we're good oh [ __ ] huh huh oh you
took your shell fail here take a shelter
oh [ __ ] is still in here Oh share mode
activated period okay share mode
activated thanks for the tip bro no
problem okay oh [ __ ] share box
really
okay I got the key second floor huh no
share mode activated pretty okay I got
the chair mom oh don't ah oh oh he
doesn't like you Wow Oh madam um give me
Latin Adam um I don't care I don't care
I don't care my haters gonna hate
I laugh cuz you're afraid I'm okay again
can I use this
yeah I made my shake except that one
time when I didn't mate in myself but
otherwise I made it myself
can we go in here I can't even walk
there Oh cruel out through a crowd it
goes that hill then he'll be a bro be a
[ __ ] bro oh I'm so screwed I'm so
screwed Daniel get the [ __ ] up ok good
job good job I'm very proud of you now
this is dark room now we're talking
darkness here
really
it's like I'm ready to dark here
and yeah I think that's the end of the
Attic cuz
uh-huh I think I fell for the floor or
something that's the thing about these
customized aren't usually very well on
weight mean but it's okay
I don't couch like I do judge [ __ ]
made this is a piece of wreath art a
piece of [ __ ] really okay okay
the doors open but apparently I can't
walk that so that's great
and if I walk in here
I fall down so I'm not going there what
about here okay yeah
good good freakin oh look at the house
look at the s it's beautiful
oh the [ __ ] you really wanted to jump
I'll save you buddy I'll say actually
not I'll let him die
Oh bah-bah bro side of the closet no no
oh man
Oh freaking man he was a hot like that I
don't like that I don't I'm not by
Stefano Susy though oh hello baby I am
so scared that was all about oh man I'm
so scared oh Savano don't say you're
scared oh yeah I'm not scared I was this
I don't get scared I'm Stefan well let's
get the [ __ ] out of this place ah man
that doll is still locked why do you why
do you know about a comeback oh okay
let's go here
oh come on Stefan oh I need your oh oh
oh oh give me a [ __ ] break up no no
no it's not cool not cool Civello
not cool no car man
a lark a paddy I have a secret for you
your school ha ha oh come on be
prosavana really ok just take it to
Haley nice and quiet don't make noises
ha ha ha ha
every freaking time I try not to miss
say that I always make okay this way
today ah it's this drunk don't worry you
just drank too much look he drank from
those look stuck sheriff's everywhere
but I need some Oh nope okay we are
screwed yes well okay we have a
flattened Adam oh it's okay we're not
entirely fine Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay great let's get out of here yep yep
yep yep yep yep I upped and hanged up
and I can go there let's oh [ __ ] what I
light that up for okay just no no no the
fun oh no no fitted hopefully hopefully
hope snow but it's no hope Oh video Oh
he's still after me he is still after me
Hey
oh come on stop please please please
okay it's good oh oh oh wow no no no yes
the final doctor me oh man oh man you're
so screw pity
what oh wait I have a kid oh [ __ ] sakes
Devon [ __ ] save Oh Donna ah I please
tell me this is right kick oh oh man we
lost the phone Allah we [ __ ] lost the
farm okay my son it is pretty [ __ ]
low right now I had did I boil up so
yeah
oh man the ad [ __ ] hit and the penis
Scully what are you doing in there I
don't know but it seemed cozy so I went
for them thank you okay I'm not gonna
ask any questions that's gonna have any
questions at all just gonna play the
piano
let it be know it when I find myself in
times of trouble mother Mary comes
I don't cost any of you I miss you I
don't dress you I don't try any I trust
you I don't browse any out of trust I
never trust any of you I don't trust
with my farm shelf and am so trouble
mother Mary comes to me speaking words
of wisdom let it be in my darkest hour
she is trying to man me to me how scary
what are you doing there I don't know I
didn't like being even definitely sit I
forgot your voice whatever
speaking wisdom planning me let it be
baby okay uh let it be let it be let me
get past come on
I'm not that fat Oh friend I'm not alone
tell me how your secret [ __ ] I'm a share
job mister share trustee you wondered
that back ha ha ha double kill ok
why is it
oh I can go here - oh no look at this
penis Susie go look at that penis okay
okay okay that's looking he's like oh
you look at my fate as I will get leo
okay okay it's not loka had his penis
totally was a bad idea looking at his
penis I told you in the last episode of
Balor discovery don't look at his penis
okay
cool cinematics
burn all those who stand in the way of
science we got the basement key now
let's find [ __ ] tastic so many shapes
I all do hi all do meeting we are
watching the cinema ok ok
so what I do here yeah oh well this was
a gangbang when he raped everyone
without huge penis
uh-huh
then we use this key ah man
ah man I thought it was a right one
what a nice gang make these guys out
here I thought that was pretty cool
oh okay he's right there but I need to
go here so it's bad for me
okay let's go here
is this the key oh yeah they're like
that apparently
Oh penis Oh [ __ ] penis oh I guess
hide here and you all been well yeah
everything is fan-fucking-tastic how
y'all doin mr. penis
I know oh man that was [ __ ] close oh
oh I need to go where he is seriously
though why are you walking there I need
to go there okay I'm just gonna go here
while you show your penis to those Oh
oh man oh [ __ ] I hit my thing ah ha ha
ha should I look back I should have hit
skip funny oh oh
penis oh man oh man okay I got this it's
a no problem
it's a no problem Emma oh that's all bro
got smashed its Colley's you're
everywhere it's not being funny anymore
Oh more oil Thank You bet that's
convenient okay I don't need oil here
maybe maybe here huh cool go go go
really cool rap really right so what are
we doing here
nothing nothing a present thank you for
making this room [ __ ] ah the work
cooperate cooperate cooperate you're a
dork
okay okay good let's go here come get
some it's out small laugh Walt over yeah
that took me long enough a lot of shares
okay let's go here wow this is fun isak
cooperate your door okay okay it's a
bottle and we got the key yeah main
sorry it's done and walk in on the
potion the story in this is so deep in
awesome okay so next up I will go back
and I will go to the storage and as we
all know Sora Jean is bad [ __ ] new
skin any game ever made that's scary at
least I don't I don't I don't
Kent is that way apparently okay let's
go back I guess yeah
so many door had never went through okay
that's that door that's that I made em
wait wait where's the phone Oh step out
up sir Joseph oh no it's not cool okay
this looks fantastic my sitter L my
bloody data hi last time I checked blood
isn't pink but whatever okay so it's got
to be this one yeah I'm a genius
for the love of God do not I look like
your mother okay that would be bad to be
like your mother I mean oh I don't trust
you oh look at those I don't trust any
of you huh
blob last and only time Derrick stayed
out of my research ah come on
pulling a strange machine
okay that was the attic hope you enjoyed
thumb of the video attitude face what do
you want to do I'll see you later bye
I'm a [ __ ] walking paradox no I'm not
threesomes with a [ __ ] Triceratops
Reptar rapping as a mocking deaf
rockstars wearing synthetic wigs made of
an wash